my name is Robert Brandis I'm the head
of business development firm switch from
syngenta coming from Switzerland just
came back and moderated the session on
food security in in India and the
question of how we can make the system
more robust against food price
volatility against environmental
challenges and I must say was a
passionate century at a great panel five
people different perspectives about it I
think it brought out that we can
actually improve productivity of farmers
we can increase their income levels we
can also reduce the environment for
pressure that we are creating in terms
of water and soil but but it takes a lot
of hard work and it's certainly a core
requirement to have the smallholder in
all of this the small or in the center
of this who needs to be enabled to get
technology access get access to market
for the produce and make sure that the
income level of farmers has really
increased great discussion on the panel
but also great questions from the
audience so I thought the insides were
really significant but you got gonna get
away with it with a view that while it's
doable still a lot of hard work that we
have to put into it